[Musique]
merci Stéphane sotarel de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu du quantal la
parentré au groupe les républicains
vice-président de la commission des
finances on va longuement parler du
budget dans quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité on l' vu dans le
journal c'est Éric Dupont moréti qui a
donc été relaxé hier après-midi par la
Cour de Justice de la République à
l'issue de son procès pour prise
illégale d'intérêt Elisabeth bne se
félicite qu'il puisse continuer à mener
son action au gouvernement elle a eu
raison de le maintenir c'est pas
ministre affaibl
aujourd'hui ça c'est la décision du du
gouvernement moi tout d'abord je veux
pas commenter la la la la décision de
justice en en tant que tel mais il y a
un point de satisfaction d'ailleurs qui
a été souligné par par plusieurs c'est
la séparation des pouvoirs le respect de
la séparation des pouvoirs et que la
justice n'interfère pas dans la vie
démocratique dans la vie politique de
notre pays me semble plutôt rassurant
parce qu'on a connu depuis depuis
quelques temps bien des séquences où où
où on avait le sentiment que les juges
la just interférait beaucoup dans la vie
démocratique de notre pays notamment
laffire François Fillon ça vous faites
référence est-ce que quand même cette
décision elle pose la la pertinence et
la question du fonctionnement de cette
Cour de Justice de la République ou ce
sont des parlementaires qui jugent les
politiques je rappelle que elle
intervient dans le cadre où on a un élu
qui est en fonction à la Cour de Justice
de la République et donc il me semble
pas tout à fait anormal connait un
système justement particulier lorsqu'on
a à juger si il a à répondre de ses
actes un élu ou un ministre qui est en
fonction mais en revanche connais un
système qui ne soit pas tout à fait
celui de droit commun dans ce cas-là ça
me semble souhaitable mais est-ce qu'il
faut quand même la pas la supprimer si
on vous écoute mais est-ce qu'il faut la
réformer peut-être en tout cas le faire
qu'elle soit mieux comprise adapté à
notre environnement institutionnel
aujourd'hui et et qu'elle ne donne pas
le sentiment mais je pense que ce n'est
pas le cas qu'il peut y avoir deux poids
de mesures ou qu'il puisse y avoir des
conditions de justice qui soit pas les
mêmes pour tous ça ça me semble
effectivement important et que ce ne
soit pas forcément compris par les
Français avec un risque de faussée qui
se creuse un peu plus entre poli Absolum
le le risque il est là mais je pense
qu'il faut aussi faire preuve de de
pédagogie mais mais mais cet argument de
bien expliquer et de bien faire
comprendre que il ne faut pas que notre
vie démocratique soit prisonnière de la
justice tout en faisant que tout
justiciable quel qu'il soit élu ou pas
puisse rendre compte de ces actes il
faut trouver ce bon équilibre on va
parler des suites de l'affaire crépool
il y a eu de nombreuses questions hier
he lors de la séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement est-ce qu'il
y a aujourd'hui de France qui s'oppose
de France face- à faceace comme disait
Gérard Colom oui la formule de de Gérard
Colomb effectivement aujourd'hui me
semble d'actualité il y a deux franceces
qui sont pas tout à fait côte à côte et
qui sont plutôt face à face avec un
fossé qui se creuse des incompréhensions
fortes des violences extrêmes qu'on a du
mal à imaginer à comprendre qu'on ne
peut que condamnerner face auquel sans
doute on on est encore un peu démuni
face face auquel aussi on a sans doute
donné un sentiment peêtre pas une
réalité trop longtemps d'impunité et et
donc il me semble important
effectivement de réagir de refaire du
commun mais aussi de rétablir une
autorité qui est bien bafouée
aujourd'hui Géral harmanin qui a annoncé
notamment vouloir dissoudre des
groupuscules d'ultra drroite trois
groupuscules d'ultra droite est-ce que
pour vous la réponse du gouvernement est
à la hauteur non je pense que c'est un
symbole c'est c'est c'est c'est sans
doute nécessaire de de il a déjà eu des
tion de gropuscule d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite et et si c'est justifié
il faut continuer à le faire pour autant
je pense qu'il y a une action de de fond
de façon à ce que dans notre pays la la
minorité agissante ou certaines
minorités agissantes n'impose pas en
permanence leur lois à une majorité
silencieuse qui qui qui on le voit
accepte de moins en moins ces situations
et et je ne voudrais pas que chacun
veuille rendre justement la justice dans
notre p pays et il faut être très
vigilant sur ce planl on va parler du
budget puisquon disait vous êtes
vice-président de la commission des
finances et le Sénat termine aujourd'hui
l'examen de la première partie de ce
budget la partie recette on va voir
comment vous l'avez modifié avec Samien
de
[Musique]
chat bonjour Samia bonjour Ren bonjour
c'estan bonjour et Samia ça fait déjà
une semaine que les sénateurs ont
commencé l'examen de ce budget 2024 ils
ont apporté plusieurs modifications oui
et d'ailleurs toutes les modifications
quasiment sur ce projet de loi de
finance elles viennent du Sénat
puisqu'on le rappelle en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a déclenché vous le savez
l'article 493 de la Constitution ce qui
veut dire que les députés n'ont pas pu
le voter ce budget du gouvernement il a
été adopté tel quel alors au Sénat le
493 ce n'est pas possible he et donc les
sénateurs ne se sont pas privés de
modifier ce budget 2024 qu' trouve trop
dépensier le gouvernement prévoit 16
milliards d'euros d'économie sur les
dépenses publiques l'an prochain pas
assez pour les sénateurs qui veulent
introduire une des économies
supplémentaires 5 milliards d'euros de
coupes supplémentaires alors comment et
bien par plusieurs mesures d'abord la
suppression du bouclier tarifaire qui
permettrait à elle seulle de réaliser
d'après les sénateurs 1 milliard d'euros
d'économie l'an prochain le bouclier
tarifaire je rappelle que c'est ce
dispositif qui a permis de limiter la
hausse des prix de l'énergie pour les
ménages depuis 2021 le gouvernement
voulait le prolonger en 2024 les
sénateurs ont dit non ils veulent
remplacer ce bouclier tarifaire par un
chèque un dispositif plus ciblé qui
serait réservé au 60 % des ménages les
plus modestes le gouvernement lui n'est
pas d'accord regardez la réaction du
ministre des comptes publ hier au micro
de Quentin calm on a pris un engagement
devant les Français les prix de
l'électricité n'augmenteront pas plus de
10 %. or l'amendement porté par la
majorité sénatoriale c'est une
augmentation des prix de 20 % des des
févriers avec un chèque un chèque mais à
la fin on sait très bien comment ça se
passe avec l'échec c'est la classe
moyenne qui paye alors est-ce que vous
assumez de dire aujourd'hui euh la
classe moyenne et la classe aisés donc
les 40 % des ménages français les plus
aisés ne doivent plus être aidés pour
payer leur factur de chauffage c'est pas
une mesure très
populaire peutêtre une mesure courageuse
alors je je je je veux juste la la
resituer dans quelques secondes dans son
contexte vous avez souligné un des
éléments majeurs de ce budget c'est le
fait démocratique le fait qu'il ne soit
pas examiné à l'Assemblée et et et donc
la nécessité que il y a un examen au
fond au Sénat le deuxième élément c'est
la dette extrême de ce budgetin on
continue à à creuser et augmenter notre
dette avec on a franchi maintenant la la
barre des des 3000 milliards
d'endettement et puis le troisième
élément c'est le déficit qui continue à
grossir la dépense qui continue à
augmenter d'où la nécessité
effectivement de de travailler sur la
réduction de la dépense comme le Sénat a
souhaité le faire je trouve un peu
paradoxal que le ministre casaznav
s'ériige ou ou ou ou
conteste le l'échec ce gouvernement qui
a fait tant de chèc depuis des années
alors que la mesure aujourd'hui que nous
proposons au niveau de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est justement d'avoir des
mesures ciblées hein c'est ça le sens en
fait de ce milliard d'économie c'est au
lieu d'avoir une réduction pour tous de
la facture énergétique sur laquelle on
pourrait revenir pour essayer d'en
comprendre surtout la cause et voir
comment on peut réformer ce fameux
marché européen de l'énergie donc au
lieu d'avoir une une facture réduite
pour tous c'est de cibler via un
dispositif qui corresponde au aux
classes moyenne et et et aux classes
inférieures ou en tout cas les les les
plus défavorisés les premier décil un
chèque qui permette justement de
répondre aux besoins de ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin et non pas de généraliser
une politique dont la France n'a plus
les moyens l'Union européenne l'a
souligné encore la semaine dernière dans
ses observations alors ça c'est pour
pour les particuliers pour les
collectivités Elisabeth borne était
devant les M jeudi dernier elle a
annoncé la prolongation de l'amortisseur
électricité pour les collectivités c'est
une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle dans son annonce on voit cet
année que dans son application il y a
loin de la coupe au lèvrre si je puis
dire he puisque de nombreuses
collectivités doivent rembourser les
avances qui avaient été consentis
l'année dernière parce qu'en fait les
collectivités gèrent bien leur budget
elles font des efforts et en faisant des
efforts elles améliorent leur situation
budgétaire parfois au détriment de
l'investissement parfois au détriment du
service public local ce qui peut poser
des questions et du coup elles sortent
de ce fameux filet de sécurité ou de
l'amortisseur pour autant il est il est
il est pertinent de le de le maintenir
pour celles qui sont le plus en
difficulté ou qui ont signé des contrats
à des moments très défavorables et qui
les engagent dans la durée Samia autre
piste d'économie votée par le Sénat la
suppression de plusieurs avantages
fiscaux oui et notamment celui qui
bénéficie au propriétaires qui louent le
leur logement en meublé touristique sur
des plateformes type Airbnb actuellement
il bénéficie d'un abattement fiscal très
conséquent 71 % le gouvernement a déjà
prévu de ramener cet abattement à 50 %
mais le Sénat veut aller plus loin et
aligner le régime fiscal des meublés
touristiques sur celui des locations à
l'année les locations dites nues
c'est-à-dire passer un abattement de 30
%. c'est une proposition de Max Brisson
qui est sénateur des pyénées Atlantique
où la crise du logement est très aigu
regardez les mesures fiscales sont aussi
des symboles qu'on envoie des population
qui n'en peuvent plus qui voient les
jeunes être logés de plus en plus loin
des zones émidemment touristiques voilà
pourquoi les élus de territoire comme
lumière le territoire du Pays-Basque
unanime demande qu'on mette fin à cette
niche fiscale qui est de plus en plus
difficile à supporter voilà donc le
Sénat veut passer l'abattement fiscal à
30 % pour lesmeuobilés touristiques mais
il prévoit quand même une dérogation
pour les zones rurales dans un
territoire comme le hautre par exemple
le Cantal le Sénat dit l'abattement
fiscal pour les meublés touristiqu dans
ces zones rurales serait fixé à 51 % et
non pas à 30 % pourquoi parce qu'il faut
bien situer cette mesure dans son
contexte comme l'a rappelé mon collègue
Max Brisson c'est sur les zones tendues
où il y a cette difficulté majeure avec
le fait que les gens n'arrivent plus à
se loger on a un problème du logement
dans notre pays et que les propriétaires
parce que c'est plus rentable préfèrent
louer forme Airbnb en tout cas sur sur
des formules très très courtes et et
saisonnières c'est vrai dans le au
Pays-Bas que c'est vrai à Paris et avec
les Jos le phénomène ne peut que
s'implifier mais c'est pas la même chose
dans les en territoires ruraux
effectivement aujourd'hui le tourisme
rural en particulier les gites ruraux
c'est une pratique qui existe depuis
très longtemps qui permet d'accueillir
de manière saisonnière des des touristes
dans nos territoires et il ne faut pas
qu'il soit bien sûr régi de la même
manière donc autant je soutiens
totalement cette mesure rbnb autant il
fallait bien sûr la différencier pour
que nos territoires ruraux ne soient pas
victimes de de de celle-ci le
gouvernement lui ne la soutient pas vous
avez peu d'espoir qu'elle soit maintenue
bah je crois que le gouvernement là pour
le coup partage plutôt l'objectif à le
constat est partagé on a je pense une
difficulté fiscale ou légistique pour
trouver la bonne formule qui ne qui
permettre à la fois d'être
constitutionnel et répondre à cet enjeu
de de justice fiscale et surtout de
politique du logement parce que le vrai
sujet de fond c'est la politique du
logement Samia autre avantage fiscal
supprimé par les sénateurs celui premier
à la FIFA oui pour attirer le siège de
la FIFA en France le gouvernement lui
avait réservé un petit cadeau dans le
budget 2024 l'exonération pour toutes
les fédération sportive internationale
de l'impôt sur les sociétés la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises CVAE la TVA et puis l'impôt
sur le revenu pendant 5 ans pour tous
ces personnels alors là encore il y a eu
une quasi une unanimité à droite et à
gauche du Sénat pour supprimer ce cadeau
fiscal fait à la Fédération
internationale de football est-ce que
vous aussi vous l'avez trouvé choquant
cet avis cet avantage fiscal promis par
le gouvernement aux fédérations Sportiv
international choquant indécent tous les
qualificatif il suffit d'écouter ce que
vous égrainez comme avantage je pense
que la FIFA n'est pas très nécessiteuse
et et et donc le fait que le
gouvernement français envisage de telles
mesures y compris individuelles pour
exonéré de d'impôt sur le revenu les
salariés de la FIFA au moment où les
Français connaissent pour beaucoup
d'entre eux des situation difficile avec
une inflation qui reste présente et la
nécessité de finir les fins de mois de
façon un peu compliquée je pense que
cette mesure est indécente indigne elle
a été introduite dans le 493 je ne sais
pas pour quelle raison et qu'est-ce qui
a présidé à cela et j'espère qu'elle ne
figurera pas dans le texte définitif en
tout cas que qui sera adopté sal
samamien on reparle des taxes autoroutes
oui hein le Sénat a introduit une
nouvelle taxe dans ce budget 2024 qui
est une taxe sur les concessions
autoroutières et sur les aéroports et
cette taxe elle est censée permettre de
financer à la fois des infrastructures
ferroviaires mais aussi des
infrastructures routières parce que
l'idée du Sénat c'est de dire que les
collectivités n'ont pas toujours les
moyens de financer les infrastructures
routières et et et c'est notamment le
cas dans votre territoire le Cantal je
crois absolument euh le le dans dans nos
territoires comme le Cantal la mobilité
passe par la route certes il faut encore
améliorer des choses sur le fer mais euh
le ferroviaire ne dessert pas l'ensemble
du territoire et donc la mobilité du
quotidien les déplacements c'est la
voiture c'est la route et donc nous
devons continuer à investir à entretenir
ce réseau routier qui est très
conséquent c'est une vision de terrain
pragmatique et pour cela nous avons
besoin de de trouver des moyens pour
financer euh ces ces travaux et cet
entretien et je me réjouis moi de
l'instauration de cette taxe nouvelle
sur des infrastructures en fait les vous
l'avez dit les aéroports et les
autoroutes alors surtout les autoroutes
en fait c'est c'est c'est une c'est une
mesure de décarbonation de nos mobilités
hein c'est comment on taxe des des des
infrastructures carbonées pour financer
le ferroviaire mais aussi les transports
du quotidien sur les territoires
j'ajoute que le le Sénat a aussi
introduit une mesure qu'on avait proposé
dans notre rapport avec mon collègue
Moré qui est les quotas carbones pour
venir compléter les moyens dont on peut
disposer pour les mobilités du quotidien
et est-ce que le gouvernement vous suit
sur cette taxe sur les autoroutes et sur
les aéroports est-ce que est-ce qu'il ce
sera maintenu potentiellement en
deuxième lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
la taxe sur les autoroutes et sur
l'aéroport oui c'est une mesure qui est
partagée qui qui sera maintenue
peut-être avec quelques ajustements le
Conseil d'État a validé le fait que
cette mesure pouvait être introduite et
surtout qu'elle n'engageit pas ou une
augmentation du tarif des autoroutes
parce que ce qu'on ne voulait pas c'est
qu'en fait ce soit l'usager de
l'autoroute qui P au fin estce qu'il y a
pas un risque au final ce soit
l'automobiliste ou le passager qui paye
non parce que ce n'est pas une taxe
spécifique à l'autoroute le le le les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
peuvent répercuter lorsqu'elles ont des
charges qui sont spécifiques à leur
infrastructure là ce n'est pas le cas on
dit un mot du l'au de la biodiversité
oui le Sénat a souhaité supprimer ce
l'OTO de la biodiversité qui était une
expérimentation je rappelle le principe
les Français sont invités à jouer au l'
gratter un ticket et une partie du prix
d'achat du ticket est reversé à des
actions en faveur de la biodiversité ça
existe déjà pour le patrimoine le lo du
patrimoine qui est fortement soutenue
d'ailleurs par le Sénat et pourtant sur
le loto de la biodiversité vous avez dit
stop on ne poursuit pas
l'expérimentation pourquoi alors pour
pour deux raisons y a une raison d'abord
qui est celle de de de l'addiction au
jeu et et peut-être que c'est en plus
surtout pour les jeunes avec une entrée
très très faible à 3 € sur un sujet qui
est cher à tous mais qui parle encore
peut-être davantage aux jeunes et donc
ne pas incité à cela et le fait que
c'est pas efficace sur le plan financier
puisqueen fait seulement je crois que
c'est 46 € pour 100 € qui qui sont
pariés qui revien sur voilà 43 c'est pas
46 sur un ticket alors que si on a une
aide directe en défiscalisation il y a
66 % qui qui permet la défiscalisation
pour celui qui fait un don à des
associations qui uvrent pour la
biodiversité donc ça nous semble pas on
va dire ni moralement ni financièrement
efficace et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on n'a pas soutenu cette mesure
c'est pas parce qu'Emmanuel Macron a
gratté a gagné la dernière fois qu'il a
gratté le l'OTO de la biodiversité non
je fais je me réjouis de de de de sa
chance pour autant je je suis pas
certain que ce soit le le le un bon
exemple que le Président de la
République promeuve euh les les les jeux
de hasard un mot plus général sur ce
budget samiia a dit un 16 milliards
d'économie c'est ce que veut faire le
gouvernement vous vous dites c'est pas
assez le Sénat veut ajouter 5 milliards
supplémentaires par-ce que c'est pas
trop et où vous les trouvez ces alors je
je je dis c'est pas assez je dis c'est
pas vrai c'est que les 16 milliards en
fait il y a 12 milliards qui sont
simplement des mesures qui étaient liées
à la crise que nous aux crises que nous
avons traversé et c'est des mesures
exceptionnelles dont on sort donc c'est
12 milliards qui ne sont pas des
économies structurelles au contraire on
continue à augmenter tous les postes de
dépenses de l'ensemble des ministères
plus de 8800 postes aussi créés en terme
d'agents public dans les ministères il
nous semble qu'on n pas sorti du quoi en
coûte et qu'on est toujours dans cette
addiction après c'est des augmentations
pour l'éducation pour la police pour la
justice certes et et il y en a qui
correspondent à des orientations
notamment en terme de sécurité police
justice vous dites que l'on que l'on
souhaite pour autant il y a un certain
nombre de de de de ces dépenses qui nous
semblent pas justifié hein notamment sur
ce phénomène d'agence effication de de
de de de notre politique publique
c'estàdire qu'on donne beaucoup d'argent
à des acteurs extérieur qui pent des
politiques publiques ça je pense qu'il
faut qu'on le regarde de plus près et il
y a un point qui est en tout cas pour
moi mais mais très cher c'est la dépense
publique ce qu'on appelle les niches
fiscales vous l'avez évoqué un peu tout
à l'heure on crée encore alors que le
gouvernement prétend combattre les
niches fiscal on en crée encore 66 dans
ce dans ce PLF et je pense que là
vraiment il faut qu'on attaque les 200
milliards de dépense fiscale et sociale
alors on sait que derrière chaque niche
il y a un chien comme on dit qui défend
sa niche mais il faut qu'on s'y mette
très très sérieusement merci Samia on
suivra le vote cet après-midi un vote
sur la partie recette et puis le budget
ça dure jusqu'au 12 décembre on suivra
tout ça merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure
à tout à l'heure pour parler de la
décision de la CGR sur Éric dupondorti
on verra ça dans le club on va voir
l'actualité dans le Cantal maintenant
Stéphane sotarel on accueille Patricia
Olivieri bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous on est ravi de vous accueillir
dans cette émission vous êtes Directrice
Déléguée et rédactrice en chef de
l'Union du Cantal Patricia on va revenir
avec vous sur l'un des sujets
d'inquiétude des éleveurs alors qu'un
accord de libre échange entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur est sur le
point d'être finalisé alors
effectivement impossible
de s'adresser au sénateur du Cantal sans
évoquer l'élevage he l'élevage qui est
le poumon économique du département
alors effectivement selon des fuites de
la Commission européenne l'accord qui en
discussion depuis pas mal de temps déjà
on le sait entre l'Union européenne et
les pays du Mercosur pourrait être signé
très prochainement début décembre nous
diton alors qu'on sera en pleine COP 28
les éleveurs redoutent cette perspective
pourquoi euh ce serait la signature la
signature entraînerait l'ouverture
accrue du marché européen à des viandes
qui sont issues de d'animaux élevés dans
des conditions diamétralement opposées
celles qui sont imposées aux éleveurs
européens tant en terme de bien-être
animal d'environnement de traçabilité
première source d'inquiétude et sachant
que on est dans un contexte structurel
pour leslevages français
décapitalisation très forte ces
dernières années qui se traduit un
million de vaches de moins donc on voit
que nos campagnes vont plus ressembler à
ce qu'elles le sont aujourd'hui et puis
en même temps on est dans un contexte où
on prend la souveraineté alimentaire du
pays euh Stéphane dans ces condition
quel peut-être l'avenir quelles sont les
perspectives pour notre élevage ma
question et forcément je connais votre
réponse faut-il s'opposer radicalement à
cet accord oui bonjour Patricia oui bien
évidemment ma ma collègue Dominique
astrasson a interrogé le gouvernement
hier sur cette question là et qui nous
inquiète beaucoup et et qui est caché
sur lequel le Parlement n'a jamais eu à
se prononcer on a tous lu que le
président Loula voulait faire aboutir
cet accord avant la fin de l'année d'où
d'où cette inquiétude et et cette
échéance annoncée on s'y oppose
fermement la ministre des Affaires
étrangères et et de l'Europe nous a
indiqué hier que la France ne laisserait
pas passer cet accord en l'état
puisqueeffectivement à tous égards hein
sur les conditions de de de de de
d'élevage sur euh les les inéquités on
parilotes hein on estement ouais
absolument absolument et puis il y a il
y a aussi euh quelque chose de de de de
de de tout bête hein c'estàd qu'on est
aujourd'hui on rentre dans la COP 28 et
et et la la première des luttes contre
le CO2 c'est de limiter les importations
et et donc de soutenir notre agriculture
notre élevage français euh pour éviter
cela donc on on reste très vigilant euh
aujourd'hui euh on a plutôt des signes
qui nous laisseraient à penser que la
France s'opposera à cet accord mais il
va falloir rester effectivement très
très mobilisé pour que réellement cet
accord ne signe pas et et en tout cas je
je vous assure de de de de du fait que
le Sénat est particulièrement mobilisé
pour s'opposer à cet accord qui est
complètement contraire à tout l'intérêt
de l'agriculture française et et
quantalienne en
particulier Patricia on va parler d'
d'un autre sujet hein c'est un sujet qui
touche évidemment pas que le Cantal qui
touche bon nombre de territoires c'est
la désertification médicale alors
effectivement Stéphane starel vous avez
été corapporteur en 2021 d'une PP d'une
proposition de loi qui visait à lutter
plus fortement plus radicalement contre
les déseres méridicaux et parmi les
propositions il y avait l'idée
d'instaurer au côté de mesures
incitatives telles qu'elles sont
telleles qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui
des mesures peut-être un peu plus
coercitives d'inciter euh par des moyens
divers et variés les médecins
nouvellement diplômés à s'installer dans
des zones peu densément pourvues ça peut
être le le cas du quantal notamment pour
le les spécialistes alors cette PPL n'a
pas abouti euh quels peuvent être les
nouveaux leviers vous toujours partisans
de ces mesures coercitives et comment
les faire aboutir alors des mesures plus
contraignantes en tout cas oui euh on
avait introduit la 4e
année post postdoctorat après 4e année
d'internat c'est un élément mais qui
suffit pas et on voit bien que toutes
les solutions doivent être doivent être
mises en place l'idée c'était d'obliger
euh la profession à se réguler faute de
quoi on porte l'idée qu'il devrait y
avoir un conventionnement sélectif pour
d'abord prioriser les département qui
qui qui les les territoires qui sont en
situation de de de de carence en terme
d'offre médicale et le Cantal en fait
partie mais il y a aujourd'hui
pratiquement 6 millions de Français qui
n'ont pas un accès
satisfaisant à au médecin donc j'ai j'ai
j'ai interpellé mon mon collègue nouveau
président de la commission des affaires
sociales du Sénat Philippe Moulier avec
qui on va mettre un GR groupe de travail
en place pour faire des propositions
reprenant la PPL que j'avais eu le le
plaisir de de rapporter et peut-être
pour le faire de manière encore un peu
plus concertée mon idée c'est comme les
dentistes ont su le faire par exemple
c'est de donner un délai où les
professionnels s'organise et et arrive à
s'autoréguler comme les dentistes ont su
le faire faute de quoi effectivement on
on devrait aller vers ce
conventionnement sélectif parce que il y
a aucune raison que des Français et des
quantaliens en particulier n'est pas
accès au soins on voit aujourd'hui toute
la difficulté que ça représente merci
Patricia Olivieri merci beaucoup d'être
intervenu dans cette émission on était
ravi on regarde la Une de l'union du
quanta l'oriaac pôul d'excellence en
matière de microbiologie c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous un dernier mot rapidement
Stéphane sotarel puisque vous êtes élu
de la région vernronalpe et on a appris
hier que avec la région Provence Alpe
coupe d'Azur vous allez donc accueillir
les Jeux olympiques d'hiver 2030 on
imagine votre satisfaction c'est une
grande satisfaction une belle victoire
pour les Alpes françaises qui sont le
premier euh domaine skiable du monde et
et et euh la région ouver grenal qui
avec la région sud effectivement s'est
associé pour accueillir cette événement
sera au rendez-vous et et et je n'ai
aucun doute que le Cantal même s'il est
au bord de cette grande région mais avec
une très belle station qui est le Luron
puisse aussi bénéficier de cet événement
merci merci Stéphane satarel d'avoir été
notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure